we've been covering the anti-woke
movement being in shambles and we have
another data point in this that I want
to show you right now a new Gallup study
finds that same-sex marriage support is
at an all-time high 71 in the United
States the highlights here are this
figure matches the highest recorded one
in history which was last year
support is lowest among Republicans and
weekly churchgoers if you're a
republican only a 49 chance you support
gay marriage if you go to church weekly
only a 41 young adults and Democrats are
the group's most supportive of gay
marriage if you look at the Historical
chart this goes back to 1996. you see
that in 1996 there was 27 support for
gay marriage another one in other words
the belief that same-sex couples should
be recognized under the law just like
opposite sex couples that has climbed
and climbed and climbed all the way up
to 71
71 if you look at different groups you
find that in terms of church attendance
the more you go to church the less
likely you are to support gay marriage
women slightly more than men support gay
marriage but the numbers are very very
very close and then basically from 50
years of age and up you're less likely
to support gay marriage the group most
likely to support gay marriage is those
18 to 29. if you went to college you're
more likely to support gay marriage than
if you didn't
obviously Democrats more likely than
Independents and Republicans to support
it regionally we see that the South has
the lowest support for gay marriage so
what does this tell us this tells us
tells us a number of different things
number one it tells us that the
so-called culture war that the right
loves to say they're prevailing in when
it comes to so-called boys and girls
Sports and woke ideology and drag and
all of these things
the right is losing
you can't find any empirical data that
the right is winning you ask about
abortion support for abortion being
legal in most situations is higher than
ever during the Roe v Wade era today
support for gay marriage higher than
ever you ask people do you think we've
done enough not enough or the right
amount when it comes to
making trans people feel welcome in
society
the majority says we have either done
the right amount or not enough that's
the and that's not the anti-woke
position I hate to break it to these
folks so that's why the right is trying
to steal elections rather than win them
they will likely ramp up their fascistic
rhetoric and it is in the data you need
only look at all of this data we have to
understand why for DeSantis and Nikki
Haley and Pence now seems to be doing it
the anti-woke agenda is not going to win
them the presidency that's for sure they
need to First figure out how to defeat
Donald Trump I am very interested to see
more as a curiosity than anything else
whether Chris Christie once he enters
the race runs on anti-woke my instinct
is that he will not but remains to be
seen and we're going to watch it very
closely